if I were to answer that using an
endocrinological framework I would say
in a sense your question can be reframed
as the difference between dopamine and
serotonin right the dopamine hits caters
to my pleasure Center so the porn or the
juicy burger is a one-time hit but
that's not existential Bliss right
that's not right so but when I sit down
and I say I am genuinely a happy person
I've got a great family I love my
children I've got great friends I can
text Dave Rubin in a second he's going
to respond uh you know I I read books
all day I am existentially happy so I
think it's really the difference between
short-term hits of dopamine and
long-term serotonin contentment which by
the way is something that we can also
relate
when you're choosing your partner right
many people will confuse you know lust
and the hormones the neural anatomy of
lust that's gonna fade I don't care
whether you're married to a Greek god
Adonis or Beyonce you know there's the
old expression show me a gorgeous woman
and I'll show you a guy who's tired of
having sex with her yeah that also
speaks to the reality that there is a
huge tedium that sets in if all you are
pursuing is short-term pleasure but on
the other hand for me to be able to go
for a walk with my wife and you know
have fun and joke around and so on
that's contentment so that's I think the
difference between them
to talk about since we've mentioned
Jordan a couple times one of the things
that he talks a lot about that I think
uh has helped a lot of people is that
your goal shouldn't be happiness your
goal should be purpose first off you do
I I sense you agree with that but can
you explain how do you how do you meld
those things and what do you see is the
difference of those things yeah so in in
the last chapter of my forthcoming
happiness book I have a quote by Victor
Frankel where he basically says you know
don't pursue directly success it is
something that comes as a consequence
and I use that because I argue that I
completely analogize that to to
happiness and hence I agree with Jordan
Happiness should be something that
results from you having adopted the
right mindsets the right decisions and
so I think you mentioned purpose and
meaning so in one of the chapters where
I talk about the two decisions that are
most likely to impart either great
amount of misery or great amount of
happiness to you I say that the choice
of spouse that you choose
and the choice of profession that you
choose are the ones that are going to do
that either make you more miserable or
or happier and to Jordan's point about
purpose uh
I wake up every day you know with
terrific gleeful I'm rubbing my hands
together in anticipation because my job
brings me great uh purpose and meaning
today I'm gonna talk with Dave Rubin
later I'm going to meet a graduate
student then I'm gonna speak to a
college in Florida then I'm going to put
up a sad truth I'm constantly in
creative mode so that's actually
something I talk about in the book that
the the surest way to find purpose and
meaning irrespective of which profession
you follow is to instantiate your
creative impulse now that's a very broad
statement because I could be a chef and
be creative I could be an architect I
could be a stand-up comic creating new
material I could be a podcaster I could
be an author and a professor but all
other things equal if you immerse
yourself in the creative impulse you're
more likely to find purpose and meaning
very few insurance adjusters probably
wake up and say
thank God I'm an insurance adjuster I
find such purpose and meaning doing that
so what do you do for that person so for
the person that's an insurance adjuster
that's watching this right now that it's
it's a it's a mundane activity let's say
they might have the great spouse they
might be making a decent living but the
day-to-day thing and I'm sure there are
some insurance adjusters who absolutely
freaking love it but whatever that job
is that whatever we're talking about
there what do you say to that person
yeah fantastic
all day
that's right so I so in a sense it
relates to some of the other uh
prescriptions that I have in the book so
I argue for example that I have a whole
chapter titled Life as a playground
right meaning that immerse yourself in
Endless play even when pursuing very
serious things so science the pursuit of
science is the ultimate form of
intellectual play right because when
you're putting together I'm going to
come to the insurance adjusted in a
second when you're putting together a
puzzle of a thousand piece puzzle you're
trying to make all these pieces fit well
that's what science is right there's a
bunch of variables out there and I'm
trying to find which one causes which
other one which one correlates to the
other or is unrelated to the other so
it's a form of orgiastic cerebral play
so to the end uh insurance adjuster I
say that perhaps your job doesn't allow
you that creative play Pursuit but then
at night when you finish your job rather
than watching television for the next
five hours maybe sign up for that
Ceramics class that you had always
wanted to take in other words there is
still a way for me to pursue my creative
impulse to immerse myself and play even
though my profession doesn't afford me
that those opportunities
what would you say to the person that's
struggling and I think this is probably
for mostly for the generation or the
several Generations now behind the two
of us
um who are struggling between the
balance between pleasure and happiness
meaning they've grown up where you can
watch porn all day long you can play
video games all day long you can indulge
in whatever it is that you like to do
all day long basically at your phone as
opposed to getting to the purpose
that'll bring you the happiness and I
think I think a huge amount of people
are struggling with that balance
so if I were to answer that using an
endocrinological framework I would say
in a sense your question can be reframed
as the difference between dopamine and
serotonin right the dopamine hits caters
to my pleasure Center so the porn or the
juicy burger is a one-time hit but
that's not existential Bliss right
that's not right so but when I sit down
and I say I am genuinely a happy person
I've got a great family I love my
children I've got great friends I can
text Dave Rubin in a second he's going
to respond uh you know I I read books
all day I am existentially happy so I
think it's really the difference between
short-term hits of dopamine and
long-term serotonin contentment which by
the way is something that we can also
relate
when you're choosing your partner right
many people will confuse you know lust
and the hormones the neural anatomy of
lust that's gonna fade I don't care
whether you're married to a Greek god
Adonis or Beyonce you know there's the
old expression show me a gorgeous woman
and I'll show you a guy who's tired of
having sex with her well that also
speaks to the reality that there is a
huge tedium that sets in if all you are
pursuing is short-term pleasure but on
the other hand for me to be able to go
for a walk with my wife and you know
have fun and joke around and so on
that's contentment so that's I think the
difference between the two do you think
a lot of people don't know what they
want in a spouse partly for what you're
saying that they're just looking for
either the sexiest person or whatever
that they just have no idea what their
actual uh what the lanes are what the
barriers are so for example did you see
the story just in the last week or so
about Jonah Hill sending these texts and
his girlfriend did you happen to see
this story yeah I did so he sent out
what I thought were were fairly uh well
said controlled statements about what
his expectations in a relationship were
don't party with your girlfriends uh you
know don't send out naked pictures like
some basic stuff and then he said hey if
this doesn't work for you I'm not the
right guy now of course everyone calls
him a misogynist and then you know all
the Press is going after him but I
thought how impressive there's someone
actually saying what they want
yes and not not apologizing for it so
two things I'll say so you probably know
the delphic maxim which is know thyself
so that speaks to your point right
because he he knows what's going to be
his
trajectory of happiness and he's saying
this is what I expect and that could
only happen if I know myself but if I'm
going to put the more General point in a
scientific framework there are two when
it comes to the evolutionary mechanisms
of human mating there are two competing
uh if you like maxims there is the birds
of a feather flock together and there's
the Opposites Attract well it may
interest your audience to know that the
overwhelming consensus in the scientific
literature for long-term happiness of a
union is birds of a feather flock
together oh interesting I would have
said it the other way wow I'll tell you
where you might be right if you said the
excitement of a short-term dalliance
right let's go behind the shed and let's
have some you know dopamine hits
metaphorically speaking then if I am
someone who is restrained who sexually
shy who's introverted and you're the
opposite you bring me out of my shell
those things those opposites might
attract and I might actually come away a
lot more enriched by the fact that we're
different but for long-term Union if we
share values if we share life goals if
we share belief systems it's
astoundingly more likely that we'll be
happy so what Jonah Hill was doing was
being a perfect darwinian being and
recognizing that he wants someone who
shares his values there's nothing wrong
with that right I wonder if in some ways
there's sort of like a big picture
little picture version of that because I
always find like if I was to look at me
and David for example we really agree on
all the big picture stuff of what we've
wanted out of life and build things
together and that's why you know
thankfully it's it knock on wood it's
worked and it's growing and all that but
we're very different in another we're
opposites when it comes to attention to
detail organization all of those things
so I guess there's probably a couple
different layers of all of this that's
why when I was referring to birds of a
feather flock together I specifically
said what those criteria are that we
should match on we're not trying to
match on our eye color we're not trying
to match on our the morphology of our
faces it's life goals it's life mindsets
it's belief systems that's what we're
talking about birds of feather flock
together incidentally on physicality by
the way there is one trait that we also
have assorted of mating and that's on
height so that if you look at naturally
occurring couples I'm talking about
heterosexual couples but we could easily
extend it to same-sex couples
there was a study that was done with 720
actual couples one of which one out of
720 that it violate the the assortative
cue of male should be taller than female
so that's a very important view the only
the only true well this doesn't bode
well for uh say Ben Shapiro if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about Academia check out
our Academia playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell